Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. In the hundreds to which Middlemarch belonged, railways were as exciting a topic as the Reform Bill or the imminent horrors of cholera, and those who held the most decided views on the subject were women and landholders. Women, both old and young, regarded travelling by steam as presumptuous and dangerous, and argued against it by saying that nothing should induce them to
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》。在《米德尔马契》所描绘的数百个城镇中，铁路就像《改革法案》或即将到来的霍乱恐怖一样，是一个令人兴奋的话题；而对这个话题持有最坚定观点的人，则是妇女和土地所有者。无论年长还是年轻的妇女，都认为乘坐蒸汽列车是狂妄自大且危险的，她们反对此事，宣称无论如何也不会
get into a railway carriage. While proprietors were unanimous in the opinion that in selling land, whether to the enemy of mankind or to a company obliged to purchase, these pernicious agencies must be made to pay a very high price to landowners for permission to injure mankind. Now that is George Eliot in Middlemarch, first published in 1870, but looking back 30 or 40 years earlier to the arrival of the railways in Middle England. Tom Holland, the railways, what an amazing subject.
坐上铁路车厢。而地主们则一致认为，在出售土地时——无论是卖给人类的敌人，还是不得不购买的某家公司——必须让这些有害的机构向地主支付极高的价格，作为允许其伤害人类的补偿。这是乔治·艾略特在1870年首次出版的《米德尔马契》中所写的内容，但她回溯的是三四十年前铁路驶入英格兰中部的情景。汤姆·霍兰，铁路，多么令人惊叹的主题啊。
I mean, transformative moment in victorian history and indeed in well in all modern history you might say well i mean there are times where um you find that uh there's been some accident or a train's been cancelled or there's a strike and a replacement bus has been laid on and um all the all the toilets are shut. They're the worst words in the English language, rail replacement bus. And it's just miserable. And you curse the railways. But then you think about the romance of it
我的意思是，维多利亚时代乃至整个现代历史上具有变革性的时刻，你可能会说，嗯，我的意思是，有时你会发现，嗯，发生了一些事故，或者火车取消了，或者有罢工，然后安排了替代公交车，嗯，所有的洗礼间都关门了。这是英语中最糟糕的词，“铁路替代公交车”。这简直太惨了。然后你会诅咒铁路。但随后你会想起它的浪漫色彩
and just the sheer kind of excitement of this. So Eric Hobsbawm compared the invention of the railways to the harnessing of the atom that this was a you know these were comparable kind of explosions of human ingenuity and what it opened up in terms of industry and ability to to kind of transform the world it's fair um and we had a we had a question about that. Olioko was the birth of the railways, the most significant development in ushering in the modern world. And, you know,
以及这种事纯粹的兴奋感。因此，埃里克·霍布斯鲍姆将铁路的发明比作原子的利用，这是一个——你知道——人类智慧的同等爆发，它在工业以及改变世界的潜力方面开启了新局面，这是公平的——我们之前有一个关于这方面的问题。奥利奥科（Olioko）想知道，铁路的诞生，是不是引领现代世界的最重大发展？而且，你知道，
it's, it's definitely up there with, I mean, obviously the printing press a few centuries earlier, maybe later the telegraph. Yeah. Do you not think Tom? Well,
这绝对名列前茅，当然，还有几个世纪前的印刷术，也许后来的电报。是的。你不这么认为吗，汤姆？嗯，
I do. I do. And of course, one of the, one of the things that gets any British heart swelling is that this is a great British invention. But one might almost say a Northumbrian invention. And so in the awareness of that, there was really only the one guest that we could ask to come on and talk about it for us. And he is sitting in Newcastle as we speak, wearing a Victorian capitalist's hat.
我确实这么认为。当然，任何英国人内心涌起自豪感的原因之一，就是这是一项伟大的英国发明。但人们甚至可以称之为诺森伯兰的发明。因此，带着这种认知，我们能邀请来为我们讲述它的嘉宾其实只有一位。此时此刻，他正坐在纽卡斯尔，戴着维多利亚时代资本家的帽子。
So he looks like Isambard King for now. It's the one and only Dan Jackson. Good evening, Dan. Good evening, gentlemen. How are you? Very well. Very well. I think all our guests from now on should wear hats.
所以他看起来就像伊桑巴德·金（Isambard King）一样。他就是独一无二的丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）。晚上好，丹。晚上好，各位先生。你们好吗？很好。很好。我认为我们以后的所有嘉宾都应该戴帽子。
Appropriate hats. It's such a shame the listeners don't get to see this hat. You really do look like the absolute image of a sort of, to be honest, you look a bit more to me, US railroad robber baron. Yes. Yes, that's a good point. I was thinking Brunel, but I'll go with that.
戴合適的帽子。听众们看不到这顶帽子，真是太遗憾了。老实说，你看起来真的很像那种——说实话，在我看来，你看起来更像是美国铁路强盗大亨。对。对，说得有道理。我本来在想布鲁内尔（Brunel），不过我也接受这个。
Yeah. Abraham Lincoln. Stovepipe. Stovepipe top hat. Well, do you know, I've just taken a screenshot, so I'll put that up as part of our Twitter advertisement. But so Dan, author of the Northumbrians, brilliant, brilliant local history of the history of the Northeast. And Dan came on pretty much this time last year, wasn't it, to talk about the regions in England.
对。亚伯拉罕·林肯。烟囱帽。烟囱高顶礼帽。你知道吗，我刚刚截了张屏，我会把它作为我们推特广告的一部分发出去。那么丹，作为《诺森伯兰人》的作者，这是一部精彩绝伦的东北部历史地方志。丹差不多就是去年这个时候来过，对吧，谈论英格兰的各个地区。
So Dan, when I asked you, I thought that we were going to be focusing very much on the Northumbrian angle. And I said to you, you know, how far do you want to go with the history of the railways? And you replied, I think it would be fun to do the origins of antiquity. You see, I didn't know that. I should have known that perhaps, but I didn't know that the origins of the railways lay in antiquity. Then the of coal then something on the cultural impact maybe then the 20th century so what's left nothing if not ambitious which is obviously why you're wearing your victorian capitalist hat yeah well it's a great story it's a great romantic story isn't it and it's a it's a it's something that changed the world but obviously inevitably, inevitably, I argue that some of its key, most important developments took place in the northeast of England. That's a stunning development.
所以丹，当我问你的时候，我以为我们会非常专注于诺森伯兰的视角。我对你说，你知道，你打算把铁路历史讲到多远？而你的回答是，我觉得探讨古代的起源会很有意思。你看，我当时并不知道这一点。也许我本来应该知道的，但我并不知道铁路的起源可以追溯到古代。然后是煤炭的起源，接着可能是文化影响，然后是20th世纪，那么还剩下什么？简直是雄心勃勃，这也显然就是为什么你戴着维多利亚时代资本家帽子的原因。是的，这是一个伟大的故事，一个伟大的浪漫故事，不是吗？这是一个改变了世界的故事，但不可避免地，不可避免地，我认为它的一些关键、最重要的发展都发生在英格兰东北部。这是一个惊人的发展。
Who'd have thought it? Okay, well, listen. So that question that I asked, do its origins lie in antiquity? I had no idea. combined with, we've got a question from Warren Allison, who asked, surely the birth of railways was when German miners in the mid 1500s brought over wooden wagonways used underground in the lead and copper mines. So is it antiquity or is it early modern Germany? Or is it neither of those?
谁能想到呢？好吧，听着。我刚才问的那个问题，它的起源是否在古代？我完全不知道。结合这个问题，我们收到了沃伦·阿利森（Warren Allison）的一个问题，他问：铁路的诞生肯定是在16世纪中期，德国矿工把用于铅矿和铜矿地下的木质运煤道带过来的时候吧？所以，它是源于古代，还是源于近代早期的德国？亦或是两者都不是？
Well, I think there's multiple origins of this story. I think what people tend to focus on in the birth of the railway story is the steam engine, and we'll come on to that, definitely. But obviously the rails, the tracks themselves, were a key part of this story, and there are some key developments in the 19th century around wrought iron technology and so on, which are absolutely crucial.
嗯，我认为这个故事有多种起源。我认为人们在铁路起源的故事中倾向于关注蒸汽机，我们接下来也会讲到这一点，这毋庸置疑。但很显然，铁轨，即轨道本身，也是这个故事的关键部分，19th世纪在熟铁技术等方面有一些关键的发展，这些绝对是至关重要的。
But the first use of a sort of trackway that you could say was the precursor of the railway was in ancient Greece. 600 BC, there was something called a diolkos, a paved trackway, which transported boats across the Isthmus of Khorinzida. Of course, yes, of course. Khorinz. So this people have been wrestling with the challenge of how do you move heavy objects across difficult terrain for hundreds of years? And then a lot of this story is related to mining and German miners. where miners in Germany are using similar sort of trackways, even proto-finicular railways, uphills and so on, to transport heavy mined goods, coal, stone, etc., across difficult terrain.
但可以说得上是铁路前身的这种轨道的最早使用是在古希腊。公元前600年，有一种叫做“地奥尔科斯”（diolkos）的东西，这是一条铺砌的轨道，用于将船只运送过科林斯（Khorinzida）地峡。当然，是的，当然。科林斯。所以几百年来，人们一直在努力应对如何将重物运过复杂地形的挑战；而且这个故事的很大一部分都与采矿和德国矿工有关，那里的矿工在德国使用类似轨道的系统，甚至是原始的缆索铁路，穿过上坡等地形，将重型开采物资、煤炭、石头等运过复杂的Terrain。
And then we start to see this appear in England and around the later 16th century, where some German miners come over to caldbeck in um in cumberland and they're working as miners there so that's probably one of the first records of what became known as wagon ways which were the grooves initially and then they moved on to become um kind of wooden rails that kind of that guided pretty primitive trucks across them to carry heavy goods. And even in my part of the world, southeast Northumberland, you see very, very early wagonways around 1605 outside Blythe
然后我们开始看到这出现在英格兰以及16世纪后期左右，当时一些德国矿工来到坎布里亚郡（Cumberland）的卡尔德贝克（Caldbeck），并在那里作为矿工工作。所以这可能是后来被称为“运煤道”（wagon ways）的事物最早的记录之一，这些运煤道最初是沟槽，然后发展成为引导相当原始的货车在其上运载重物的木轨。甚至在我所在的地区，即诺森伯兰东南部，你在1605年左右布莱斯（Blythe）外面就能看到非常非常早期的运煤道。
inevitably transporting coal. And by the early 18th century, these have proliferated to such an extent that they're well known around the country, and they're known as Newcastle Roads. Dan, I hate to do this to you. 1605. But in 1604, there is a funicular...
不可避免地用于运送煤炭。到了18th世纪初，这些运煤道已经大量涌现，以至于在全国各地广为人知，被称为纽卡斯尔路。丹，我很抱歉这么打断你。1605年。但在1604年，有一个缆索……
Something happening in Shropshire, Dominic. There is a funicular railway in Shropshire. Oh, no. So, I was rosely, which carries coal for James Clifford from his mines down to the river seven so i think shropshire i don't think wiltshire contributed to this at all well tom i i read online tom if this will cheer you up that there is some kind of trackway a very prehistoric trackway
什罗普郡正在发生一些事情，多米尼克。什罗普郡有一条缆索铁路。哦，不。所以，是在罗兹利（rosely），它为詹姆斯·克利福德（James Clifford）从他的矿井运送煤炭到塞弗河（river seven），所以我认为什罗普郡，我认为威尔特郡对此根本没有贡献。好吧，汤姆，我在线上读到过，汤姆，如果这能让你高兴的话，那就是有一种轨道，一种非常史前得轨道。
in the somerset levels oh good oh good in Oh, good. In the Valley of the River Brew. Have you been researching in the Bodleian again? This is my close research that I do in the Bodleian Library five minutes before the podcast. Oh, the River Brew, as in Bruton. As in Bruton, exactly. So anyway, Shropshire, clearly the place where the railways began, steeped in railway history.
位于萨默塞特湿地（somerset levels）。哦，太好了，哦，太好了。哦，太好了。在布鲁河（River Brew）流域。你又在博德利图书馆（Bodleian）做研究了吗？这是我在播客开始前五分钟在博德利图书馆做的深入研究。哦，布鲁河，就像布鲁顿（Bruton）那样。正如布鲁顿那样，没错。所以无论如何，什罗普郡，显然是铁路发源的地方，沉浸在铁路历史之中。
But I suspect, Dan, you may have a different take on um because obviously well shropshire they also have plates metal plates they use in coalbrookdale which is obviously the birthplace of the industrial revolution in shropshire in the 1760s but dan i suspect you may have, I mean, I think probably maybe the fairest, the sensible thing to say, I guess, is that all across coal producing areas of the British Isles, people are experimenting with different kinds of trackways and they're using, first, what, wooden? Yeah. What are we, in the 18th century? I suppose in the 16th, 17th century, they're using wooden. And then at what point did they move towards metal?
但我猜，丹，你可能对……有不同的看法，因为很明显，什罗普郡，他们也有板块，他们在1760年代的什罗普郡的科尔布鲁克代尔（coalbrookdale）使用金属板，那里显然是工业革命的发源地。但丹，我怀疑你可能会……我的意思是，我认为也许最公平、最明智的说法是，我想，在英伦三岛的所有产煤区，人们都在试验各种不同的轨道，他们首先使用的是什么？木制的？是的。我们是在18th世纪吗？我想在16、17世纪，他们使用的是木制的。那么他们是在什么时候转向金属的呢？
Well, I think the first recorded iron rails were laid in bath, actually, in the 1760s. That's wonderful. I thought I was going to be completely left out of this as a sudden. Bruton and Bath? Yes, yes. And as I said, the story of the rails themselves is sometimes overlooked. And I think you get a lot of technological developments starting to come to a head in the early 19th century, which I think is arguably the key moment.
嗯，我认为有记载的第一条铁轨实际上是在18th世纪60年代铺设在巴斯（Bath）的。太棒了。我以为我会被完全排除在外。布鲁顿和巴斯？是的，是的。正如我所说，铁轨本身的故事有时会被忽视。我认为你会看到许多技术发展在19th世纪初开始走向成熟，我认为这可以说是关键时刻。
Several places claim to have the first railways. We've explored some of them. But then it's this alignment of the railway technology itself with steam engine technology. You know, Newcomen pioneered it in the early 18th century, then James Watt in the later 18th century. And the combination of steam engines and rails is when this story really starts to come. Because, Dan, you mentioned um ancient greece and railways but of course the ancient greeks also had steam engines which they in alexandria they
几个地方都声称拥有第一条铁路。我们已经探讨过其中一些地方。但随后，是铁路技术本身与蒸汽机技术的这种结合。你知道，纽科门（Newcomen）在18th世纪初开创了它，然后是18th世纪后期的詹姆斯·瓦特。而蒸汽机和铁轨的结合，才是这个故事真正开始……因为，丹，你提到了古代希腊和铁路，但当然古希腊人也有蒸汽机，他们在亚历山大港
developed the principle of the steam engine and used it basically for for kind of exotic gimmicks in temples but there's a famous counterfactual written by arnold toynbee in his you know multi-volume history of the world where he imagines what would have happened had the Macedonians developed the steam engine. And he has a kind of vision, obviously influenced by the time he was writing what was happening with the British, of Macedonian steam engines. Yeah. Armoured trains. Armoured trains going across Mesopotamia to suppress rebellions in babylon so i anyway i this is kind of you know it's a what if but i just throw that out that once again because it's very
开发了蒸汽机的工作原理，并将其基本上用于神庙中的各种异国噱头。但阿诺德·汤因比（Arnold Toynbee）在他的多卷本世界历史中写过一个著名的反事实假想，他想象了如果马其顿人开发出蒸汽机会发生什么。他有一种愿景——显然受到他写作时英国人现状的影响——即马其顿的蒸汽机。是的。装甲列车。装甲列车穿过美索不达米亚去镇压巴比伦的叛乱。所以无论如何，这是一种“如果……会怎样”的假设，但我只是把它提出来，因为这再次非常
in our time isn't it everything begins with the greeks oh i think it began in each greece so anyway i sorry i've interrupted there so so the steam engine so yeah so that's cornwall as well isn't it yeah well if you think about trevithick but again you mentioned not the word novelty there tom and i think with with the work of trevithick you've got um uh his i think it's called catch me if you can uh one of his one of his early steam engines this is very early uh 19th century 1804 um But it's seen as a novelty. People go on rides on it in London and so on, and it goes around a circular loop. But we're still waiting for that technological breakthrough
符合我们的时代，不是吗？一切都始于希腊人。哦，我认为它始于古希腊。所以无论如何，抱歉我刚才打断了——所以蒸汽机，是的，所以这也是康沃尔郡的产物，对吧？是的，如果你想想特里维西克（Trevithick），但你再次提到了“新奇”这个词，汤姆，我认为随着特里维西克的工作，你有了——嗯——他的，我想它叫“抓我如果你能”（Catch Me If You Can），这是他的早期蒸汽机之一，这是非常早期的——19th世纪初，1804年——但它被视为一种新奇事物。人们在伦敦等地乘坐它兜风，它在一个环形轨道上行驶。但我们仍在等待那个技术突破，
to really combine the rails and the steam engine in a really practical and commercially viable way. And where did that happen? Well, I think the spur for this is war, an interesting name. Oh, okay. Napoleonic Wars causes a shortage of horses and causes a shortage, a rise in the price of horse fodder. So people are looking for alternatives to horsepower
将铁轨和蒸汽机以一种真正实用且具有商业可行性的方式结合起来。那是在哪里发生的呢？嗯，我认为这背后的催化剂是战争，一个有趣的名字。哦，好吧。拿破仑战争导致马匹短缺，并导致马饲料短缺以及价格上涨。因此人们正在寻找马力的替代品，
because all these wagonways we've discussed were horse-drawn. That's how they worked. You even have things called, we'll come on to George Stevenson in a moment, but he invented the dandy wagon where you could, in places like the northeast, you could utilize railways, just you could utilize gravity on railways to kind of go downhill. And he invented a dandy wagon to put the horse in a little cabin, into freewheel down the hill, and then the horse would be kind of harnessed up
因为我们讨论过的所有运煤道都是靠马拉的。它们就是这样运作的。你甚至还有这样的东西——我们一会儿会谈到乔治·斯蒂芬森（George Stevenson），但他发明了“花车”（dandy wagon），在东北部这样的地方，你可以利用铁路，只需利用铁路上的重力就可以下坡。他发明了一辆花车，把马放在一个小车厢里，让它顺着山坡滑行，然后马会被套上
to pull the thing back up the hill on the other side. But it's the spur of war. So you get some real breakthroughs around 1812. There's a locomotive engine invented by a Newcastle man actually called Matthew Murray, but he's working in Leeds at the time. And this engine's called the Salamanca, named after the battle that was just taking place in the War. And then you get Puffing Billy, which is a further development by William Headley on the banks of the Tyne at Killingworth. Again, it's connected to a colliery. How can we get this coal from the pit head out for export in the River Tyne? So, Dan, just to quickly clarify, these things are generally driven by coal.
用来把东西从另一边拉上山。但战争是催化剂。所以在1812年左右，你获得了一些真正的突破。有一台机车是由一个名叫马修·默里（Matthew Murray）的纽卡斯尔人发明的，但他当时在利兹工作。这台机车被称为“萨拉曼卡”（Salamanca），是以战争中刚刚发生的战役命名的。然后你有了“普芬比利”（Puffing Billy），这是威廉·海德利（William Headley）在基林沃思（Killingworth）的泰恩河畔进一步开发的成果。同样，它与一个煤矿有关。我们如何把这些煤从矿井口运出来，以便在泰恩河出口？所以，丹，简单澄清一下，这些东西通常是由煤炭驱动的？
Yes. Is that right? Yes. So that's why you need, I mean, almost all the instances we talked about, so the Trevithick, I mean, he was Cornish, but his thing was developed for a colliery, I think, in Merthyr Tydfil.
是的。是这样吗？是的。这就是为什么你需要——我的意思是，几乎我们谈到的所有例子，比如特里维西克，虽然他是康沃尔人，但他的东西是为梅瑟蒂德菲尔（Merthyr Tydfil）的一个煤矿开发的，我想。
Yeah. So basically, had it not been, I mean, that's why it's Britain, right? Because of the coal, I guess. Is that right? Yeah, just the sheer volumes of coal that are being produced in Britain at the time and the challenge of moving this stuff around.
所以基本上，如果不是因为这个——我的意思是，这就是为什么是英国，对吧？因为煤炭，我猜。是这样吗？是的，只是当时英国生产的煤炭数量庞大，以及运送这些东西的挑战。
I mean, there's some, the developments of canals in other parts of the country were part of that solution. It really takes off in the northeast because the topography in the northeast doesn't lend itself to canals very easily. We've got these navigable rivers, the Tyne and the Weir, where pretty much you could roll the coal down the hill uh in most places and get it out for export to uh the rest of the country and around the world but the sheer volume of coal the challenge of shifting that
我的意思是，在国家其他地方运河的发展是解决方案的一部分。它之所以在东北部真正腾飞，是因为东北部的地形不容易开通运河。我们有这些可通航的河流，泰恩河和韦尔河（the Weir），在大多数地方，你几乎可以把煤炭顺着山坡滚下去，运出去出口到全国其他地方和世界各地，但煤炭的绝对数量以及转移这些东西的挑战
stuff led to these led to these developments in in locomotion and because he had the plentiful supply of the the fuel source uh on hand and this is when when george stevenson enters the scene i think who is one of them well he's i think he's one of the great figures of um of british history and he's an almost entirely self-made man in fact samuel smiles the only great proponent of victorian self-help wrote an incredibly um popular biography of him in the 1850s. Because he did a whole series of Lives of the Engineers, didn't he? Yes.
促成了这些机车技术的发展，因为他手头就有充足的燃料来源——而这时乔治·斯蒂芬森登场了，我认为他是——嗯，他是英国历史上的伟大人物之一，他几乎是一个完全靠自己白手起家的人。事实上，维多利亚时代“自助”唯一的伟大倡导者塞缪尔·斯迈尔斯（Samuel Smiles）在1850年代写了一本关于他的极其受欢迎的传记。因为他写了一整套《工程师传》，不是吗？是的。
And Stevenson's seen as a bit of a paragon because he's born in a coal mining village called Wylam in the Tyne Valley. But usually his parents were illiterate, and he was himself until he taught himself to read and write at the age of 18. It was quite an illiterate area, actually. But nonetheless, George Stevenson he entered the mining trade like his father at a very early age and one of Stevenson's first jobs in the pit is that almost laughably dangerous job which is sometimes known as a fireman or it was sometimes also described as a penitent which was because coal mines are extraordinarily dangerous with flammable gases
斯蒂芬森被视为某种道德楷模，因为他出生在泰恩河谷一个名为怀拉姆（Wylam）的采煤村。但通常他的父母不识字，他自己也是，直到18岁时才自学读写。那其实是一个文盲率相当高的地区。但尽管如此，乔治·斯蒂芬森像他父亲一样在很小的时候就进入了采矿业，斯蒂芬森在矿里的第一份工作之一就是那项荒谬危险的工作，有时被称为“消防员”，有时也被描述为“忏悔者”，这是因为煤矿里充满了极其危险的可燃气体，
and there was always explosions killing people. Stevenson's job was to dress himself in damp rags and damp clothing, go in with a lighted torch and ignite pockets of flammable gas. That was his job. How old was he then? He's in his teens doing this.
总是发生炸死人的爆炸。斯蒂芬森的工作就是穿上湿抹布和湿衣服，拿着点燃的火把进去，点燃那些可燃气体的口袋。这就是他的工作。他当时多大？他当时十几岁在做这件事。
Oh my God. So health and safety is not there. Absolutely not. But he got interested in steam engines because they were often used to pump out water. Pits were often flooding. And he's just one of these guys that's sort of intuitively good at fixing stuff. He became known as an engine doctor because he had this kind of instinct on how to repair and fix. He was like a tinkerer.
哦，天哪。所以当时根本没有什么健康和安全保障。绝对没有。但他对蒸汽机产生了兴趣，因为它们经常被用来抽水。矿井经常被淹水。他正是那种直觉上很擅长修理东西的人。他被称为“发动机医生”，因为他有一种如何修理和解决问题的直觉。他就像个修补匠。
Yes, exactly. Exactly. He reminded me a bit of my father. You know, he kind of instinct on how to repair and fix like a tinkerer yes exactly exactly yeah you reminded me a bit of my father you know he kind of turned his hand to anything that sort of one of those sorts of guys so he wasn't taught anywhere how to do this he just kind of had this intuition to do it and inevitably he got interested in locomotive engines and his first was in 1814 and it was called the blucher named after the prussian field marshal so another link to warfare yeah yeah so this is when he starts the end turns out late so setting yeah yeah that's how it would carry on but your point dominic's absolutely right the tinkering aspect.
是的，完全如此。完全如此。他让我想起了我的父亲。你知道，他那种凭直觉应付各种事情的劲头，就是那种类型的人。所以没有人教他怎么做，他只是有这种直觉去做，并且不可避免地他对机车发动机产生了兴趣。他的第一台机车是在1814年，名叫“布吕歇尔”（blucher），是以普鲁士陆军元帅的名字命名的——所以这又是一个与战争的联系，是啊，所以这就是他开始……所以，好吧，事情就是这样继续下去的，但是你的观点，多米尼克的观点绝对是正确的，关于修补匠的方面。
And a lot of his early work on these locomotive engines was on what was the best weight distribution to ensure that the thing travelled along the rails. What was the best method of adhesion, you know, with the engine and the trucks. Because that's been seriously proposed as a reason why britain is the center of the industrial revolution is that it had a culture of tinkering kind of messing around fiddling with stuff um and you said contraptions and things
他早期对这些机车发动机的大量工作都是关于什么是最好的重量分布，以确保东西沿着铁轨行驶。什么是附着力的最佳方法（你知道，发动机和货车之间）。因为这曾被认真地提出来作为英国成为工业革命中心的理由，即它有一种修补的文化，也就是到处瞎搞、摆弄东西，
so it's appropriate that we're meeting uh discussing this in um 2022 because it's the 200th anniversary of what was probably his major breakthrough in in locomotive history is um the hetton railway which was just outside sunderland it's the birthplace of bob paisley actually and on the um paisley gates at anfield they've got the the shield of hetton which is a small town in County Durham and on the shield is a locomotive from that from that period and it's one of it's one of Stevenson's and what's unique about the the Hetton railway is it's the first track it's eight miles long it's basically built to get coal to the river Weir from the pit head but it's the first one that uses entirely
你提到了各种奇怪的装置和东西。所以我们齐聚一堂讨论这件事非常合适，2022年是他的机车历史上的重大突破——赫顿铁路（hetton railway）二百周年纪念，该铁路就在桑德兰（sunderland）郊外，实际上是鲍勃·佩斯利（Bob Paisley）的出生地。在安菲尔德（Anfield）的佩斯利大门上，有赫顿（Hetton，位于达勒姆郡的一个小镇）的盾形纹章，盾形纹章上就是那个时期的机车，它是斯蒂芬森的机车之一。赫顿铁路的独特性在于它是第一条轨道，全长八英里，基本上是为了把煤炭从矿井口运到韦尔河，但它是第一条完全使用
locomotive power rather than horsepower. Does it still exist? Parts of it still exist, yeah. And there's a number of bicentenary events taking place this year to record that. So it was a real breakthrough. But of course, Stevenson and his son, Robert, were involved in some of the mining engineering at the same time to penetrate beyond the magnesium layer underneath Hetton to get at the riches of the coal underneath, which that alone was seen as an amazing engineering breakthrough.
机车动力而不是马力的铁路。它现在还存在吗？部分路段仍然存在，是的。今年将举行一系列两百周年纪念活动来记录这一点。所以这是一个真正的突破。当然，斯蒂芬森和他的儿子罗伯特当时也参与了一些矿业工程，以穿透赫顿下方厚厚的镁质层，获取下方丰富的煤炭资源，仅此一点就被视为一项惊人的工程突破。
And then they invented the locomotive and the railway line to go with it as well. So they were real pioneers. And so at what point does he start doing the stuff that he's really famous? You know, the sort of Lady Bird book. The Rocket. The Rocket. Exactly.
然后他们发明了机车和与之配套的铁路线。所以他们是真正的先驱。那么他是在什么时候开始做那些让他真正成名的事情的呢？你知道，那种“瓢虫”少儿读物里的。火箭号。火箭号。没错。
That's what I was thinking. The Liverpool-Manchester line. And the sort of, well, we're going to, so first you have the Stockton and Darlington Railways. Does that come before Liverpool-Manchester? It does, doesn't it? Yes. 1825.
这正是我所想的。利物浦-曼彻斯特铁路线。还有那种——好吧，我们打算——首先你有了斯托克顿和达灵顿铁路（Stockton and Darlington Railways）。那是在利物浦-曼彻斯特线之前吗？确实是的，对吧？是的。1825年。
So what's the story there, Dan? Well, it's a similar one they want they need to get the coal out of the fairly isolated uh part of southwest durham around bishop walkman shill's and that sort of area and they want to export it out of the teas uh the river teas so they construct a railway uh between they call it stockton and darling but it goes a bit further than that inland towards the the collieryy District. And Stevenson's given the job. He builds the famous locomotive called Locomotion. Is that why, here's the question,
那么那里的故事是怎样的呢，丹？嗯，这是一个类似的故事，他们需要把煤炭从达勒姆郡西南部相对偏远的一个地区（比如毕晓普奥克兰（Bishop Auckland）和希尔斯（Shildon）一带）运出来，他们想把它从蒂斯河（the Tees）出口。因此，他们在他们称之为斯托克顿和达灵顿的地方之间修建了一条铁路，但它的延伸范围比那还要深入内陆，直达煤矿区。
is that why all locomotives are called locomotives from that name or were they already called locomotives? That's a good question. I'm going to go to the Bodleian and research that. I'll have to look that up in the Bodleian. Yeah. No, I mean, they must be called locomotive engines because they're generating locomotion.
斯蒂芬森被委以重任。他建造了著名的机车，名为“机车号”（Locomotion）。这就是为什么——这里有个问题——这就是为什么所有的机车都从那个名字被称为机车，还是它们以前就被称为机车？这是个好问题。我要去博德利图书馆查阅一下。我得去博德利图书馆查查这个。
Yes, indeed. And what's unique about this one, it wasn't just pulling freight, which previous colliery railways had done this one they attached a um a passenger carriage which they called the experiment and so people rode along uh you would all aboard the experiment what could possibly go wrong but did anything go wrong no no it was all fine and so that's what is that what then gives him the idea for well it's what makes his name because it's such a um uh a successful um and it's the
是的。不，我的意思是，它们一定被称为机车发动机（locomotive engines），因为它们在产生运动（locomotion）。确实如此。这列火车的独特之处在于，它不仅拉货——以前的煤矿铁路都是这么做的——它还在上面挂了一节乘客车厢，他们称之为“实验号”（the experiment），所以人们可以随车同行。大家都上“实验号”！会有什么差错呢？但出差错了吗？没有，没有，一切都很好。这就是给他灵感的原因吗？
longest i'm trying to remember the exact distance of the stockton and darlington it's it's um maybe i should really google that while we're talking. But it's a number of miles between. I think it's around about 20 miles distance. And I would locate this in, I think I talked when we were last on about the Northumbrian Enlightenment, which takes place roughly the same time as the Scottish Enlightenment. And in a moment that I think you could only describe as sacral. Oh, damn.
好吧，这成就了他的名声，因为它是如此成功，而且它是——我试图记住斯托克顿和达灵顿铁路的确切距离。它是——也许我应该在我们说话的时候真的去谷歌一下。但它之间有相当多的英里数。我想大约是20英里左右的距离。我把它归类为——我想我们上次来的时候谈到过诺森伯兰启蒙运动，它大约发生在与苏格兰启蒙运动同时代。在一个我认为你只能将其描述为神圣的时刻——哦，丹。
That was shameless. The engine. I thought we were safe from that in a Railways podcast. The fire in the engine of locomotion is lit from the rays of the sun. Oh, yes. By the engine driver's pipe glass, which is a little sort of magnifying glass that people used to light their pipes. I love that.
太厚颜无耻了。发动机。我还以为我们在铁路播客里能免受这种梗的侵害呢。运载“机车号”发动机的点火源来自太阳光线。哦，是的。通过火车司机的烟斗玻璃，那是一种人们用来点烟的小型放大镜。我喜欢这个。
That's great. How romantic is that? That's fabulous, isn't it? So he makes his name on the Stockton and Darlington, and then we're heading into the Rainhill Trials and the Liverpool and Manchester Railway. So they've set up that railway, and they're what? They're running trials to find out the best engine?
这太棒了。这有多浪漫啊？这太棒了，不是吗？所以他凭藉斯托克顿和达灵顿铁路成名，然后我们前往雷恩希尔试车（Rainhill Trials）以及利物浦和曼彻斯特铁路。所以他们建立了那条铁路，他们在做什么？他们在进行测试以找出最好的发动机？
Is that basically what that is the one an efficient commercially viable means they it's the it's the the the business community you might say of manchester manchester and liverpool which is the real kind of cockpit of and so they in the 19th century so they they they have been looking at what Stevenson's been doing, have they? And thinking, we can carry passengers as well as freight from Manchester to Liverpool. I mean, particularly the freight
那基本上就是那场试车的目的吗？寻找一种高效、商业上可行的手段。它是——曼彻斯特和利物浦的商业界（你可以这么说），那是19th世纪真正的核心地带，所以他们在19th世纪——他们在关注斯蒂芬森在做什么，对吧？并且认为，我们可以把乘客以及货物从曼彻斯特运到利物浦。我的意思是，尤其是货物
aspect, again, because of the textile industry, you know, the raw material comes to Liverpool. But the passenger element of it is important as well, right? I mean, that's... Yeah. It's sometimes overlooked, but actually by the early 19th century,
方面，同样是因为纺织工业，你知道，原材料运到了利物浦。但客运元素也很重要，对吧？我的意思是，那是……是的。这有时被忽视，但实际上到19th世纪初，
the road network in Britain is pretty advanced. You know, you had the advances of the invention of tarmac and tarmac-macadamised roads and all that sort of thing. But they were increasingly congested they were still pretty slow because again it's horse-drawn carriages and so on so they're looking for a mass transit system i suppose you'd call it uh between these two vitally important in uh industrial and economic centers and hence the uh the rainhill trials, which Stevenson submits and enters an engine called the Rocket, which is actually designed by his son, Robert, who is just, in fact, an even more impressive engineer in many respects.
英国的公路网已经相当发达了。你知道，你有了柏油路面和碎石路面发明方面的进展以及诸如此类的东西。但它们日益拥堵，而且速度依然相当慢，因为毕竟它们是马拉马车等等，所以他们正在寻找一种大众运输系统（我想你会这么称呼它），在这两个至关重要的工业和经济中心之间建立起来，因此也就有了雷恩希尔试车，斯蒂芬森在其中提交并参赛了一台名为“火箭号”的发动机，该发动机实际上是由他的儿子罗伯特设计的，从许多方面来看，罗伯特实际上是一位更加令人印象深刻的工程师。
And that wins the trial. This is 1829. And Rocket reaches a top speed of 29 miles an hour, which is just, no one had ever. Nobody. So nobody had ever gone that fast. Never. No human had ever gone that fast. No, no, you know,
而它赢得了试车。这是1829年。“火箭号”达到了每小时29英里的最高时速，这简直——从来没有人——没有人。所以从来没有人走得那么快。从来没有。没有任何人类曾走得那么快。没有，没有，你知道，
horse can't gallop that fast. It's just incredible. You read the, um, the accounts of it and, and people are kind of blown away, aren't they? Yeah.
马都跑不了那么快。这简直不可思议。你读到关于它的……各种记载，人们简直惊呆了，不是吗？
They're kind of swooning, aren't they? They can't comprehend it. I mean, so even, uhbert louis stevenson i mean much much later and he has his famous phrase faster than fairies faster than witches just kind of a sense of the almost supernatural or yeah dare i say sacral we've had it already it's not sacral it's it's lost you might as well just say it it's an eeriness quality of the eerie isn't it
他们简直要昏厥了，不是吗？他们无法理解。我的意思是，甚至罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂芬森（Robert Louis Stevenson）——我的意思是，晚得多的时候，他有那句著名的诗：“快过仙女，快过女巫”（Faster than fairies, faster than witches）——这简而言之就是一种近乎超自然的感觉，或者——我敢说是神圣的？我们刚才已经用过这个词了。这不是神圣的，这是——它已经失传了，你不如直接说它有一种诡异感，对吧？
yeah so that's why presumably I mean the sense of excitement at the speed is presumably one reason
嗯，所以这就是为什么——据我推测——人们对速度的兴奋感大概就是为什么
why the opening of that railway which is a year later in 1830 is this colossal public occasion I mean one of the great
那条铁路的开通（一年后的1830年）成为一个如此巨大的公众盛事的原因。我的意思是，在某些方面，它是维多利亚时代最伟大的公众盛事之一。
Victorian public occasions in some ways and who comes to that opening event well I mean Dan will know this so the prime minister i mean it's big enough that the prime minister goes right the duke of wellington yeah i mean going back we talked about the polio yeah we've got the hero of the wars who is now you know a very sort of reactionary prime minister he pitches up doesn't he and you have this amazing scene which enshrines the railways i think i i would say more than anything else in the public imagination is you've got the very first
谁参加了那场开幕活动？我的意思是，丹会知道这一点——首相。我的意思是，规模大到连首相都去了，对吧？威灵顿公爵。是的，回想起我们谈论的拿破仑战争——我们有了战争英雄，他现在（你知道）是一位非常反动的首相，他露面了，不是吗？你看到了这个令人惊叹的场景，它将铁路铭刻在了公众的想象中，我想说，比其他任何东西都要深刻：你有了乘客铁路的第一次
trial of this passenger railway and somebody dies dan do you want to tell the story i think you know the gory details don't you dominic about the the mp for liverpool i i enjoy i enjoy stories about i think they're very good stories for children and of course you know if I enjoy stories about... Naming. Yeah, I enjoy that. I think they're very good stories for children. And, of course, you know, in all good bookshops, you will find excellent history books these days for children, which we don't need to go into. So there's a fellow called...
试运行，然后有人死了。丹，你想讲讲这个故事吗？我想你了解血腥的细节，对吧，多米尼克，关于利物浦议员的事？我喜欢——我喜欢关于……的故事，我认为这些是非常适合儿童的故事。当然，你知道，如果我喜欢关于……的故事。命名。是的，我喜欢。我认为这些是非常适合儿童的故事。而且，你知道，在所有优秀的书店里，你现在都能找到适合儿童的优秀历史书，我们不必深入探讨这个。所以有一个家伙叫……
His name is Huskisson. It's William Huskisson, isn't it? And he is a... He's been a sort of frontline politician, but he wasn't a great ally of the Duke of Wellington. So he stepped back a bit since the Duke of Wellington became PM. And he's been ill. And his doctors actually say to him,
他的名字叫赫uskisson。是威廉·赫斯基森（William Huskisson），对吧？他是一个——他曾是一位一线政治家，但他并不是威灵顿公爵的忠实盟友。所以自从威灵顿公爵当上首相后，他退居幕后了一点。他生病了。他的医生实际上对他说：
don't go to the opening of this railway. He just had surgery, hadn't he? He just had surgery for a kidney. And he's a very clumsy man. He's always falling over and losing his balance, which is an important aspect of the story. So he goes specially because he wants to get in with... He's the MP for Liverpool as well. I mean, that's a crucial part of it.
千万别去参加这条铁路的开通仪式。他刚刚做过手术，不是吗？他刚刚做了一个肾脏手术。而且他是一个非常笨拙的人。他总是摔倒、失去平衡，这是这个故事的一个重要方面。所以他专门前去，因为他想和……搞好关系。他也是利物浦的国会议员。我的意思是，这是至关重要的一部分。
So it's expected that he's there. So he goes and he goes in this special train that's been built for the Duke of Wellington and all his guests. And that train is pulled by... You'll enjoy this, Dan, if you don't know it already, by a locomotive called... The Northumbrian. The Northumbrian. How good's that?
所以人们期望他在那里。于是他去了，他乘坐了为威灵顿公爵及其所有客人们建造的这辆特别列车。而那列火车是由——如果你不知道的话，丹，你会喜欢这个的——一台名为“诺森伯兰号”的机车拉动的。诺森伯兰号。这有多棒？
So that's been driven by Stevenson himself, by George Stevenson. Could there be anything more Northumbrian than George Stevenson driving a train called the Northumbrian? It's chugging along and it stops at a place called Parkside, which is a station called
所以那是斯蒂芬森本人亲自驾驶的，由乔治·斯蒂芬森驾驶。还有什么比乔治·斯蒂芬森驾驶一辆名为“诺森伯兰号”的火车更具诺森伯兰特色的呢？它喘着粗气前进，在一个名为
Parkside, which is near St. Helens. And there Huskisson gets out and lots of people kind of go down the track to shake hands with the Duke of Wellington. Presumably he's leaning out of his compartment or they're kind of leaning in or something. And
帕克赛德（Parkside）的地方停了下来，那是一个名为帕克赛德的车站，靠近圣海伦斯（St. Helens）。就在那里，赫斯基森下了车，许多人顺着铁轨走下去，与威灵顿公爵握手。大概他是把身子探出车厢，或者他们正把身子探进车厢之类的。
Huskisson goes and does this. It's very important to him that he can shake hands with Wellington and kind of bury the hatchet or whatever. It's like if Jeremy Hunt was on a train with Boris Johnson. He goes on the train to shake hands with him or something. And then they see the rocket coming the other way. And the tracks are quite close together, aren't they? I think there's about four or five feet between the tracks.
赫斯基森也去这么做了。对他来说，能够与威灵顿握手并“冰释前嫌”或者别的什么，是非常重要的。这就像杰米·亨特（Jeremy Hunt）和鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）坐同一辆火车一样。他上了火车去跟他握手之类的。然后他们看到“火箭号”从相反方向开过来。铁轨靠得很近，对吧？我记得铁轨之间大约只有四五英尺。
So the rocket is coming the other way. And somebody says, an engine is approaching. Take care, gentlemen. Mind the gap. Yeah, basically between the tracks. So the rocket is coming the other way, and somebody says, an engine is approaching. Take care, gentlemen. Mind the gap. Yeah, basically mind the gap. And most of the people who are sort of loitering about immediately get off the track. But Huskisson, and this is where you're clumsy, he's clumsy.
所以“火箭号”从相反方向开过来，有人喊道：“一辆机车正在接近。先生们，请小心。注意间隙。”是的，基本上就是注意间隙。大多数在周围闲逛的人立刻离开了铁轨。但赫斯基森——这就是你说的笨拙，他很笨拙。
So unaccountably, rather like sort of Inspector Clouseau style or something, he keeps falling over. I read Bodleian Library. He made two attempts to get off the track, but kept kind of falling back onto it. So the rocket is getting closer and closer, and people are sort of saying, for God's sake, man, get off the tracks.
因此，莫名其妙地，有点像彼得·塞勒斯（Inspector Clouseau）风格之类的，他不断摔倒。我读过博德利图书馆的资料。他曾试图两次离开铁轨，但一直不知何故又跌回了铁轨上。所以“火箭号”越来越近，人们纷纷大喊：“看在上帝的份上，老兄，快离开铁轨。”
And he's just falling over and shambling about and eventually there's this terrible scene where he decides that the the way to he could have flattened himself against the duke of wellington's train and there was enough space to to for the other train the rocket to pass but what he ends up doing is sort of trying to get into the duke of wellington's carriage and then it turns into something from almost like a bond film so he's he grabs the um people sort of trying to drag him in but duke well it actually says to him we seem to be going on you'd better step in so so this sort of great meeting with the prime minister hasn't quite you know at this point going to plan not not really going to plan he's sort of embarrassing himself in front of the prime minister huskisson tries
而他却只是在跌跌撞撞、挪来挪去，最后出现了这个可怕的场面：他认为——他本可以把自己紧贴在威灵顿公爵的列车上，那样空间就足够让另一辆列车“火箭号”通过了，但他最终做的事却是试图钻进威灵顿公爵的车厢，这结果变得有点像007电影里的场景——他抓住了……人们试图把他拉进去，但威灵顿公爵实际上对他说：“看来我们要继续前行了，你最好上车。”所以这个与首相的伟大会面此时并没有完全按计划进行……
to clamber into the carriage but but he doesn't make it and some people he's going to falls backwards again somebody shouts to him for god's sake mr huskisson be firm and at that point huskisson grabs the door of the carriage and just as the rocket reaches him the door swings open with him on it into the path of the rocket and he falls down on the track and the rocket runs over his legs
并没有真正按计划进行。他在首相面前显得有些出丑。赫斯基森试图爬进车厢，但他没有成功，有些人——他又要往后倒了。有人对他大喊：“看在上帝的份上，赫斯基森先生，坚强点！”就在那时，赫斯基森抓住了车厢门，“火箭号”正好驶到他跟前，车门带着他一起荡开，撞向了“火箭号”的运行轨道，他倒在了铁轨上，“火箭号”从他的腿上碾了过去。
and you know what he says he says they run and pick him up and he says very sort of Shakespearean you know I am slain. He says, uh, it's all over with me. Bring my wife and I may die.
你知道他说什么吗？他们跑过去把他扶起来，他说了一句非常莎士比亚风格的话：“我被杀害了。”他说：“一切都结束了。把我的妻子带来，我好瞑目。”
And he does. And well, he does eventually. The weird thing is that people said that he, he, he didn't seem that hurt at first. And the train did less damage to his legs than people thought was likely. That's kind of weird thing,
他确实……好吧，他最终确实死了。诡异的是，人们说他——一开始似乎并没有伤得那么重。火车对他的腿造成的损害比人们想象的要小。这有点诡异，
isn't it? With the Duke of Wellington and people losing their legs. Lord. Oxbridge, isn't it with the duke of wellington and people losing their legs lord again oxbridge isn't it yeah lord oxbridge my god sir i've lost my leg good god sir so you have yeah yeah basically the lesson of this story is never stand next to the duke of wellington because you're going to lose your legs but the new is it right dominic that the impact of this is so huge that weirdly it acts as a kind of amazing advert? So you would think, this is the weird thing about this story, you would think people wouldn't want to get on the train after this.
不是吗？威灵顿公爵和人们失去双腿。天哪。牛津，不是吗？跟威灵顿公爵在一起，人们失去了双腿，天哪，又来一个牛津，不是吗？是的，乌克斯布里奇勋爵（Lord Uxbridge）。天哪，长官，我失去了一条腿。上帝保佑，长官。所以你确实失去了——是的，基本上这个故事的教训就是永远不要站在威灵顿公爵旁边，因为你会失去双腿。但是，多米尼克，这是真的吗：这件事的影响如此巨大，以至于它奇怪地起到了某种神奇广告的作用？你会认为——这个故事诡异的地方就在于此——你会认为在这之后人们不会想坐火车。
But no, the railway is absolutely deluged with people afterwards. Isn't that right, Dan? Yeah, yeah. It's an enormous success. It's a sensation, isn't it? Because it's so exciting. It's attracting all these VIPs right from the very start. You too could lose your legs.
但并没有，事后铁路涌入了大量的人。不是这样的吗，丹？是的，是的。这是一个巨大的成功。这是一个轰动效应，不是吗？因为它太刺激了。从一开始它就吸引了所有这些VIP。你也有可能失去你的双腿。
I know I mentioned this, I think, in the Industrial Revolution episode we did. But have either of you seen a documentary called The Day the World Took Off? No. It's about the day the rocket goes on its first journey along the the mantis liverpool railway and it it it pin it kind of identifies it as the the key moment when you know industrial world gets lift off and it has these
我想我在我们做的那期工业革命节目里提到过这个，不过你们俩看过一部叫《世界腾飞的那一天》的纪录片吗？没有。它讲的是火箭号在曼彻斯特和利物浦铁路（Mantis Liverpool Railway）上进行首次通车的那天，它某种程度上将其确定为工业世界腾飞的关键时刻，并且片中有那种
wonderfully kind of formalized scenes of the rocket going past horses people throwing their toppers in the air tom you've played it's so good it's so good that you could you played william of normandy on screen haven't you i think you'd be an excellent duke of wellington oh thanks i think if you were that we could reenact it you could be wellington yeah i think dan is yeah i i've played and dan would be... Isn't Barton Brunel? Well, no, Dan... He'd be George Stevenson. George Stevenson, yes, okay. Yeah, he'd be George Stevenson.
非常精彩、形式化的场景，火箭号从马匹身旁驶过，人们把大礼帽抛向空中。汤姆，你演过——太棒了，太棒了，你曾在银幕上扮演过征服者威廉，对吧？我觉得你会成为一个出色的威灵顿公爵。噢，谢谢。我觉得如果你演那个角色，我们就能重演历史，你可以演威灵顿。对，我觉得丹会……巴顿·布鲁内尔？哦，不，丹……他会演乔治·斯蒂芬森。乔治·斯蒂芬森，对，没错。好吧。对，他会演乔治·斯蒂芬森。
I think it would be absolutely splendid. I think once the rest of his history moves on to film, that should be our first production. Well, okay, so when will we three meet again? I think when we do meet, we should definitely stage the death of William Huston yeah let's do that at the station and see how it goes what could possibly go wrong I think on that on that stunning note we should possibly take a break here and when we come back we should look at the explosive
我觉得这绝对棒极了。我觉得等《历史其余部分》（The Rest is History）以后搬上大银幕，那应该成为我们的第一部作品。好吧，那么我们三个人何时才能再相聚呢？我想当我们再聚时，我们绝对应该把威廉·休斯顿（William Huston）的死给重现一下。对，我们就按那个在车站排演一下，看看效果会怎么样，能出什么岔子呢？我觉得带着这种惊艳的调调，我们大概应该在这里休息一下，等我们回来后，我们应该看看维多利亚时代英国铁路的爆发式
growth of the railways in Victorian Britain. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
增长。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你们获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的每周必听节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家播客以及提前购买现场活动门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Let the great world spin forever down the ringing grooves of change. That was Alfred Tennyson in his 1842 poem, Loxley Hall. And it's one of the kind of the lines that sums up the sense of dynamism and change and growth that Victorian Britain represented. But it was actually founded on a complete misapprehension. Tennyson wrote, when I went by the first train from Liverpool to Manchester in 1830 I thought that the wheels ran in a groove it was a black night and there was such a vast crowd around the train at the station that we could not see the wheels and then I made this line so Dan the fact that Tennyson gets it so wrong gives you a kind of brilliant sense of just how novel and
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。让伟大的世界在变革的轰鸣轨道上永远旋转下去。这是阿尔弗雷德·丁尼生在他1842年的诗作《拉克西霍尔》（Locksley Hall）中的名句。它完美概括了维多利亚时代英国所代表的那种充满活力、不断变革与增长的精神面貌。但它其实建立在一个完全的误解之上。丁尼生写道，当我在1830年乘坐从利物浦开往曼彻斯特的第一列火车时，我以为车轮是在凹槽里运行的，那是一个漆黑的夜晚，车站周围围着黑压压的庞大人群，以至于我们根本看不到车轮，于是我写下了这句诗。所以丹，丁尼生错得这么离谱，正好让你有一种精妙的感受，那就是在1830年，
strange this technology that we're seeing showcased in 1830 with Stevenson and the rocket and everything, just how strange it was to people. It was strange. It was thrilling. It was incredibly exciting. And I've got a passage from Elizabeth Barrett Browning's kind of blank verse poem, Aurora Lee, which is written in the 1850s. And there's almost a slightly sexual tinge to a lot of this. Ooh. Yeah. I'll warn listeners to brace themselves for this,
随着斯蒂芬森和火箭号以及这一切的亮相，这项技术对于当时的人们来说是多么新颖和陌生。它确实很陌生。它令人心潮澎湃，令人难以置信地兴奋。我有一段摘自伊丽莎白·巴雷特·勃朗宁的无韵长诗《奥罗拉·利》（Aurora Lee）的文字，这首诗写于18世纪50年代。这里面其实带有一丝微微的性暗示。哦。对。我要提醒听众们做好心理准备，
because she's writing about, and this, if anyone's seen the final scene of North by Northwest with Cary Grant, which I saw recently laughed out loud. Oh, yes. But she's writing about the tunnels that she traveled through. We might get onto the kind of the civil engineering aspect of this in a moment.
因为她写的是——如果有人看过加利·格兰特主演的《西北偏北》的结局，我最近看过，当时笑出了声。哦，是的。但她写的是她穿过的那些隧道。我们稍后可能会谈到这其中的土木工程方面。
So she writes, and shot through tunnels like a lightning wedge by great four hammers driven through the rock, which quivering through the intestine blackness splits and lets in at once the train swept in a throb with effort trembling with resolve the fierce denouncing whistle wailing on and dying off smothered in the shuddering dark while we self-awed drew troubled breath oppressed as other titans underneath the pile, a
所以她写道：“如同一枚闪电楔子射穿隧道，由伟大的四重之锤穿透岩石驱动，在腹腔般的黑暗中颤抖着裂开，让狂飙突进的列车瞬间涌入，伴随着奋斗的脉搏，带着决心颤抖，凶猛刺耳的汽笛声呼啸着拉长又渐渐消逝，在令人战栗的黑暗中窒息，而我们带着对自我的敬畏，呼吸着困顿的空气，如同被压在石堆底下的其他泰坦一般，
nightmare of the mountains, out at last, to catch the dawn afloat upon the land. I mean, flying. That's great stuff. That's like the Meg Ryan scene in Harry Met Sally. It's amazing. Because the Liverpool
一场群山的噩梦，终于冲了出来，去捕捉那浮游在大地上的晨曦。”我的天，飞驰而过。写得太棒了。这就像《当哈利遇到莎莉》里梅格·瑞恩的那场戏。太惊人了。因为利物浦
to Manchester line had some pretty formidable civil engineering challenges to overcome itself. You know, all the mosses of South Lancashire, the marshy ground and so on. But then you start to see through figures like Robert Stevenson, who I mentioned earlier, who did have an education unlike his father. In fact, George Stevenson, who was known as Geordie Stevenson, because men in the North East called George get that nickname, one of the more plausible origins, I think, of the Geordie descriptor for people from the North East is because George had to go down to Parliament
到曼彻斯特的铁路线本身就需要克服相当艰巨的土木工程挑战。你知道的，南兰开夏郡的所有沼泽地，泥泞的地带等等。但随后你开始通过像罗伯特·斯蒂芬森这样的人物看到这一点——我刚才提到过他，他确实接受过教育，这与他的父亲不同。事实上，乔治·斯蒂芬森被称为“乔迪·斯蒂芬森”（Geordie Stevenson），因为东北部的人把叫乔治的男性都起这个昵称。我认为，东北部人被称为“乔迪”这一称呼比较可信的起源之一，是因为乔治不得不经常去议会
to give evidence often for railway building schemes to get acts of Parliament through. And people couldn't understand him. So they would mock his Geordie accent. So there's other theories that it was because of loyalty to the Hanoverian Georges in the Jacobite rebellions, or it was George Stevenson's miner's lamp, which is known as a Geordie lamp.
为铁路建设方案作证，以便让议会法案通过。人们听不懂他在说什麽。于是他们会嘲笑他的乔迪口音。所以还有其他理论认为，这是因为在詹姆斯党起义期间对汉诺威乔治国王的忠诚，或者是因为乔治·斯蒂芬森的矿工灯，它被称为乔迪灯。
But I quite like this one. So he took care to make sure that Robert Stevenson had a proper gentleman's education, Edinburgh University and so on. And he was a bit more refined than all Geordie. But Robert Stevenson was one of these pioneers of civil engineering. You know, the Killsby tunnels outside Birmingham,
但我挺喜欢这个说法的。因此，他格外确保罗伯特·斯蒂芬森接受了真正的绅士教育，去爱丁堡大学等等。他比老乔迪要文雅一些。但罗伯特·斯蒂芬森是土木工程领域的先驱之一。你知道的，伯明翰郊外的基尔斯比隧道（Killsby tunnels），
which were described as the greatest civil engineering project since the building of the Great Pyramids. All these embankments and earthworks and viaducts and bridges just incredible so dan who who who is who is paying for this i mean how where is the money coming from it and how is it that these lines are being laid well the source of the capitalism there's an interesting and pretty lively debate at the moment that this about slavery yes um that that the the payoffs to former slave
被描述为自建造金字塔以来最伟大的土木工程项目。所有这些路堤、土方工程、高架桥和桥梁都简直不可思议。那么，丹，究竟是谁在为这一切买单呢？我的意思是，这钱是从哪里来的？这些铁路线又是如何铺设的呢？嗯，关于资本的来源，目前有一个有趣且相当激烈的争论，那就是关于奴隶制的争论。是的，嗯，对前奴隶主的赔偿金，
owners many of much of that capital found its way in investment into the railways but there's also a growing middle class that are looking for places to invest their money there's the industrialists themselves who can see the commercial advantages of much better communications and so but but so it's but you've so you've got the um the manchester liverpool one but then is it other companies are saying that's a great idea let's we want to do this and we'll start building up exactly yes so so there's a lot and is there any regulation you know it's a bit of a free-for-all to be honest and you start to get these piratical figures emerging like george hudson the railway king there's no
其中很大一部分资本最终作为投资流入了铁路；但与此同时，也出现了一个寻找投资场所的不断壮大的中产阶级；还有实业家们自己，他们看到了更好交通带来的商业优势。所以呢……但你有曼彻斯特-利物浦铁路，然后其他公司也会说“这主意太棒了，我们也想这么干，我们要开始建设”，对吗？完全正确，是的，所以有很多——有没有什么监管？老实说，这有点像是一场自由混战，你开始看到一些海盗式的人物涌现出来，比如“铁路大王”乔治·哈德逊。对于这些发展，其实并没有什么
guiding hand really over the development of these i mean major major um uh civil engineering projects and building of railways require acts of parliament but it's there's there's no central planning to this and that's one of the things that start to perturb robert stevenson who could see that this was becoming a bit of a a, potentially. And there's also the lively debates about the standard gauge. Right. Okay. So the Stevenson one is narrow, isn't it? Yeah. It's four foot eight and a half inches, which is, people have said, isn't it a coincidence that it's the same width as chariot wheels and so on? But basically, they were using horse-drawn vehicles as the prototypes for their carriages.
指导方针。我的意思是，重大、重大的土木工程项目以及铁路建设确实需要议会法案，但这其中并没有中央规划，这也是开始让罗伯特·斯蒂芬森感到困扰的事情之一，他能看出这正在变成一个潜在的……而且，关于标准轨距也存在着激烈的争论。对的。好的。那么斯蒂芬森的轨距比较窄，对吧？是的。是四英尺八英寸半，正如人们所说的那样，难道这和战车车轮的宽度等等一样是个巧合吗？但基本上，他们当时是以马车作为车厢的原型的。
So it's pretty inevitable that it's going to be that width. Whereas Brunel favoured the broad gauge, which is, I think, now almost seven feet wide. And going back to the Acts of Parliament, I mean, that's obviously a massive bonanza for corruption, isn't it? Because basically, you need somebody to introduce a bill on your behalf to allow you as the capitalist, as the railway baron, to get the land, to get the rights to the land. Dominic, we've got a question from Queequeg on the Discord, which you get if you're a member of the Restless History Club. Oh, very good answer.
所以它最终会是那个宽度几乎是不可避免的。然而，布鲁内尔则青睐宽轨，我想现在它几乎有七英尺宽。回到议会法案这事上，这显然是腐败的巨大温床，对吧？因为基本上，你需要有人代表你提出一项法案，允许你作为资本家、作为铁路大亨去获得土地，获得土地的使用权。多米尼克，我们收到了来自Discord上奎奎（Queequeg）的一个问题，如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”（Restless History Club）的会员，你就能看到。哦，回答得非常好。
Sensational, sensational answer. Very good answer, St Tom. How did railroads gain right-of-way through private land? Was this a politicised process? Did corruption occur? I imagine corruption did occur, did it? Yeah, I mean, there were huge scandals. There was this sort of sense in the mid-19th century,
太轰动了，太轰动了。回答得太好了，圣汤姆。铁路是如何通过私有土地获得通行权的？这是一个政治化的过程吗？是否发生过腐败？我想腐败肯定是发生了的吧？是的，我的意思是，曾有过巨大的丑闻。在19世纪中期，有一种看法——
correct me if I'm wrong, Dan, but that politics had been, you know, that the interests of the kind of, the entrepreneurs, the railway entrepreneurs, had enmeshed with, you know, sort of parliamentary bigwigs who were just sort of pocketing money in order to push through these bills.
丹，如果我错了请纠正我——那就是政治已经，你知道的，那些企业家、铁路企业家的利益，已经和那些议会里的权贵们纠缠在了一起，这些人只是在把钱揣进自己腰包，以便强行推动这些法案通过。
Isn't that right, Dan? Yeah, pretty much. A lot of money was changing hands, legitimately and illegitimately, I think. And also the aristocracy cottoned on to the fact, initially I think many of them were quite hostile to what's this, you know, coming across my land. But the value of just pure agricultural land, if it didn't have mineral resources underneath, it was declining.
难道不是吗，丹？是的，差不多吧。大量的资金在易手，既有合法的，也有非法的，我想。而且贵族们也意识到了这一点——起初我想他们中的许多人对“这算什么，竟然修到我的地盘上来了”这种事相当敌视。但纯粹农业用地的价值，如果下面没有矿产资源的话，一直在下降。
But actually access rights over your land, like the earls of Derby agricultural land, if it didn't have mineral resources underneath, it was declining. But actually, access rights over your land, like the Earls of Derby outside Liverpool, you know, they're great Lancashire barons. They made a packet from, you know, having that access over their land. So it's a bit of a bonanza. Because apparently, initially, when they were mapping out the line of the Liverpool-Manchester railway, the surveyors took a posse of prize fighters.
但实际上，在你土地上的通行权，比如利物浦郊外的德比伯爵（Earls of Derby），你知道的，他们是兰开夏郡的大地主。他们通过拥有在其土地上的通行权赚了一大笔钱。所以这有点像是一笔横财。因为据说最初在规划利物浦-曼彻斯特铁路线时，测量员们带了一群职业拳击手。
Yes. That's a good story. Yeah. To do what? To like punch up sort of. Well, to guard them, to protect them. Yeah. Well, obviously there's a lot of.
对。这是一个好故事。是的。去干嘛？去把某种人痛打一顿吗？嗯，为了守卫他们，为了保护他们。是的。好吧，显然有很多人……
The landed interests were so hostile. There is resistance, isn't there? I mean, famously, there are places like Cambridge where the railway station is quite a way out of the town centre because basically people want to keep out at arm's length. And that quote from Middlemarch, you know, there are a lot of people who always, you know, one of the sort of subplots of Middlemarch is hostility to the railways. You know, I think the thought that it's going to bring modernity, but that being a bad thing and destroy your community and all that sort of stuff. There is a bit of that, isn't there, in the mid-19th century? But it's interesting how quickly that is overcome.
地主阶层是如此敌视。确实存在抵抗，不是吗？嗯，众所周知，有些地方比如剑桥，火车站距离市中心相当远，因为基本上人们想把它远远地隔开。还有《米德尔马チ》（Middlemarch）里的那句话，你知道的，有很多人总是——你知道，《米德尔马契》的一个支线情节就是对铁路的敌视。你知道，我认为人们认为它会带来现代性，但这却是一件坏事，会摧毁你的社区等等之类的事情。在19世纪中期，确实有那么一点这种情绪，不是吗？但有趣的是，这种情绪被克服得有多么迅速。
And, you know, having a grand station is seen as the kind of sine qua non of any self-respecting Victorian town. And that brings us to the extraordinary building boom that's associated with the railways. If you think about, well, inevitably I'm going to say this is the first great railway station is Newcastle the first great iron kind of railway shed those kind of elegant struts over
而且，你知道的，拥有一个宏伟的车站被视为任何一个有自尊心的维多利亚时代城镇的必不可少之物。这就把我们带到了与铁路相关的非凡建筑热潮。如果你想一下——好吧，我不可避免地要这么说，第一个伟大的火车站是纽卡斯尔站吗？那是第一个伟大的钢铁类铁路棚吗？铁路线上那些优雅的支柱，
the railway lines themselves with the grand neoclassical frontage by John Dobson and it is like a cathedral with the kind of nave and aisle. Like a cathedral, Dan. Like a cathedral. Did you hear that, Dominic? I did hear that, yeah.
配上约翰·多布森（John Dobson）设计的宏伟的新古典主义门面，它就像一座大教堂，有着中殿和侧廊。就像一座大教堂，丹。就像一座大教堂。你听到了吗，多米尼克？我确实听到了，是的。
It's sacral quality. I can't say over it, but no. Very much. And if you ever, you know, the confidence of the Victorians as well, if you pulled out Newcastle Station heading north and you notice how the line skims the Norman Castle, the new castle, they almost knocked it down. But it kind of works.
它有一种神圣的特质。我不能说超越了它，但确实如此。非常如此。而且如果你曾经——你知道维多利亚时代的人的自信也是如此，如果你从纽卡斯尔站出发向北行进，你会注意到这条线路是如何擦着诺曼城堡（Norman Castle）、那座新城堡（the new castle）边缘掠过的。他们差点把它给拆了。但它某种程度上确实起作用了。
It's just the Victorians just... Well, in Berwick, I mean, in Berwick, the station's built in the middle of the castle. It's kind of amazing. On platform three, there's a kind of sign saying, this is where Edward I awarded the throne to John Balliol. Would you like a coffee? And I just wondered specifically about London, which obviously is the largest city in the world.
维多利亚时代的人就是……好吧，在贝里克（Berwick），我的意思是，在贝里克，车站是建在城堡中间的。这简直太惊人了。在三号站台上，竖着一个牌子，上面写着：“这就是爱德华一世将王位授予约翰·巴里奥（John Balliol）的地方。您要来杯咖啡吗？”我只是特别想知道伦敦的情况，它显然是世界上最大的城市。
So there's a lot of kind of, you know, it's quite, it's one thing to build a railway across empty fields, but to build it across inhabited land, such as you have in London and Dominic quoted the Middlemarch but one of the other famous passages from Victorian literature describing this process is at the beginning of Dombey and Son where Dickens describes the railway going through Camden and the kind of process of destruction and again is that is that a kind of presumably it's not kind of centrally organized this again is private companies just bulldozing their way through i think it i think it's private companies i don't know what dan thinks i think i mean you've got what scores hundreds well more than a hundred private companies by the end of the 19th century if you think about tommy and london so they're building houston but you think about arch which
所以有很多这种——你知道的，在一片空地上修建一条铁路是一回事，但在有人居住的土地上修建它，比如你在伦敦所看到的那样，多米尼克引用了《米德尔马契》，但维多利亚文学中描述这一过程的另一段名篇是在《董美父子》（Dombey and Son）的开篇，狄更斯在其中描述了铁路穿过卡姆登（Camden）以及那种破坏的过程。再次请问，这是一种——这大概不是由中央统筹规划的吧？这又是私营公司强行推平过去的吗？我想这——我认为这是私营公司，我不知道丹是怎么想的。我的意思是，到19世纪末，你有几十、几百，甚至超过一百家私营公司，如果你考虑到汤姆在伦敦的情况。所以他们在修建尤斯顿站，但如果你考虑到阿奇（Arch），
is the largest art largest classical art yeah these aren't built by central government central government doesn't really have the it doesn't really have the the ambition the kind of the the apparatus i mean central government doesn't do these these things are done by private interests in the victorian period let's take the underground i mean obviously the another you know one of the most emblematic railways of all the underground lines develop i mean the reason the underground map is is as it is it's because they develop through private interests completely higgledy-piggledy completely unplanned duplicating each other you know stations with the same name that are two different stations
也就是最大的古典主义拱门——是的，这些可不是由中央政府修建的。中央政府其实并没有那种野心，没有那种机构。我的意思是，中央政府不干这种事。在维多利亚时期，这些事情都是由私人利益集团来做的。我们来看看伦敦地铁。我的意思是，显然，这是另一个最具象征意义的铁路系统。所有这些地铁线路的发展——我的意思是，地铁图之所以是现在这个样子，是因为它们完全是通过私人利益集团发展起来的，完全是杂乱无章的，完全没有规划的，互相重复的，你知道的，有着相同名字但却是两个不同车站的车站，
or stations that are basically the same station with two different names you know just a shambolic process and that is all through the late 19th century. You have people. I mean, there's always talk about nationalization. So from the late, from the second half of the 19th century, always people saying of monopolization. Yeah. And people, well, they start to combine because actually railways become a bit less profitable as time goes on.
或者是基本上是同一个车站却有两个不同名字的车站，你知道，这完全是一个混乱的过程。而这一切都发生在19世纪末。你会看到人们——我的意思是，一直都有关于国有化的讨论。所以从19世纪后期，也就是19世纪下半叶开始，总有人在谈论垄断化。是的。而且人们——嗯，他们开始合并，因为实际上随着时间的推移，铁路变得没那么赚钱了。
So you stop making so much money after. But in the heyday, I mean, I read that they were more valuable than the East India Company. They are, but there's a big boom and bust, isn't there, Dan? Isn't there a big sort of... The 1840s is the railway mania. Railway mania. There's a huge bubble that eventually these stocks
所以后来你们赚钱没那么多了。但在全盛时期，我读到过它们的价值甚至超过了东印度公司。它们确实如此，但这里经历了一个巨大的繁荣与萧条周期，不是吗，丹？难道不是经历了一种巨大的……19世纪40年代是“铁路狂热”（railway mania）。铁路狂热。这是一个巨大的泡沫，最终每个人都在购买的这些股票
that everyone's buying have become overvalued and there is a crash at the end of the 1840s where much of that kind of free-form, messy sort of growth of the railways, it coincides with that period. But then there's a sense of government starting to step in. You've got voices like Robert Stevenson arguing for some direction to this, some standardisation. And interestingly as well, you know, some of the things we talked about, about the obliteration of time through the speed of the railways, you get things like the standardization of time itself, which, you know, railway timetables obviously rely on the country moving to a standardized system of time, which is an amazing thought, really, because before was it was a kind of laissez-faire
变得价值被高估了，并在19世纪40年代末迎来了崩盘，铁路那种自由形式的、杂乱无章的增长在很大程度上与那个时期重合。但随后人们感觉到政府开始介入了。你开始听到像罗伯特·斯蒂芬森这样的声音，呼吁为这一进程提供一些方向、一些标准化。有趣的是，你知道的，我们讨论过的一些事情，比如通过铁路的速度来抹去时间的差异，你得到了诸如时间标准化本身这样的东西，你知道的，铁路时刻表显然依赖于全国转向一个标准化的时间系统，这真是一个惊人的想法，真的，因为在此之前，这是一种自由放任的
attitude so we the adoption standard adoption of greenwich meantime across the whole of the country as part of that rational progress of the victorian age is a part of that story definitely um as well as the time you know before um was it ajp taylor who said that up until the napoleonic wars it basically took napoleon the same length of time as it would Caesar to get from Rome to Paris and vice versa? Whereas after that, I think before they built the high-level bridge over the Tyne to connect it with Newcastle Station, in the 1840s, you could get from London to Gateshead
态度。所以我们在全国范围内对格林威治标准时间的普遍采用，作为维多利亚时代理性进步的一部分，绝对是那个故事的一部分。嗯……除了时间之外，你知道，在……难道不是A·J·P·泰勒（A. J. P. Taylor）说过，直到拿破仑战争为止，拿破仑从罗马到巴黎以及反之所需的时间，基本上和凯撒大帝差不多吗？而在此之后，我想在泰恩河上修建高水平大桥以将其与纽卡斯尔站连接起来之前，在19世纪40年代，你大约可以在
in about, I think it's nine hours. That's just extraordinary, isn't it? Considering it would have taken four days, something like that. But Dan, you were saying about the gauges, that that complicates it. And apparently, so the Great Railway timetable is Bradshaw's. This guy Bradshaw develops it. And Punch has one of its many rib ticklers, where it says that the only volume more complex than Bradshaw's was the catalogue of the great exhibition.
九个小时内从伦敦到达盖茨黑德（Gateshead）。这简直太不可思议了，不是吗？考虑到这在以前可能需要四天左右的时间。但丹，你刚才提到轨距的事，这把事情搞得更复杂了。据推测，伟大的铁路时刻表是布拉德肖（Bradshaw）的。这个叫布拉德肖的人开发了它。《笨拙》（Punch）杂志曾刊登过其众多的幽默笑话之一，其中说，比布拉德肖的时刻表更复杂的唯一卷宗，就是伟大博览会的目录。
But presumably part of the reason for that is that you've got all these different companies. So they've all got kind of different, you know, very difficult to kind of mesh them. But also that you have these different gauges and you're going along, you to a different gauge you have to get off get on another train a bit like um spain and france was for a long time yes and the indian railways were always broader i think so so so and and the great figure who who broadens the gauge is brunel so just how does brunel fit into this story because he is kind of the absolute you know know, Stevenson is the archetype of the early age of the railways. Brunel is the archetype of the kind of the heroic heyday. Well, he is, but he's quite a useful civil engineer, but he's not a great actual engineer compared to Robert Stevenson, who would often lock horns with him. They were good friends. They were kind of commercial rivals to an extent.
但推测其中部分原因在于你们有这么多不同的公司。所以它们都有各种不同的——你知道的，要把它们融合起来非常困难；而且还因为你们有这些不同的轨距，当你前行时，如果遇到不同的轨距，你就不得不下车换乘另一辆火车，有点像西班牙和法国长期以来的那样。是的，印度的铁路一直都比较宽，我想是的。所以，将轨距变宽的伟大人物是布鲁内尔。那么布鲁内尔是如何融入这个故事的呢？因为他某种程度上绝对是——你知道的，斯蒂芬森是早期铁路时代的典型代表，而布鲁内尔则是英雄全盛时期的典型代表。嗯，他是，但他是一个相当有用的土木工程专家，但与罗伯特·斯蒂芬森相比，他并不是一个真正伟大的实际工程师，后者经常会与他意见相左。他们是好朋友。在某种程度上，他们也是商业竞争对手。
But it was Robert Stevenson arguing for the narrow gauge and he won out um brunel was arguing it was experimenting with things called did they call it the atmospheric railway which is kind of a complicated system of pressure to propel trains along rather than using um basically you know coal power and steam locomotion so he's often going on these flights of fancy that the very pragmatic and hard-headed Robert Stevenson would just be sitting shaking his head going, what's he doing now? But you mentioned the Great Exhibition, Tom,
但罗伯特·斯蒂芬森主张窄轨并最终胜出。布鲁内尔则在试验一些东西，他们称之为“大气铁路”（atmospheric railway）吗？这是一种相当复杂的压力系统，用来推动火车前进，而不是使用基本上你知道的煤炭动力和蒸汽机车。所以他经常进行这种异想天开的尝试，而非常务实且头脑清醒的罗伯特·斯蒂芬森只会坐在那里摇着头想：“这家伙现在又在搞什么鬼？”不过汤姆，你刚才提到了伟大博览会，
which is a useful segue into what the railways ushered in was kind of mass spectator events. I mean, Dominic mentioned London Underground. The London Underground is so old that some of the first passengers on it went to watch public hangings. That's an amazing detail. That's an amazing detail.
这倒是一个很好的过渡，铁路所开启的是一种大众化的奇观活动。多米尼克提到了伦敦地铁。伦敦地铁的历史如此悠久，以至于它最早的一些乘客当年是去观看公开绞刑的。这是一个惊人的细节。这是一个惊人的细节。
What a marble arch. I think it was a bit around Farringdon, you know, around there. Oh, right. But Farringdon's a very, very early one, isn't it? Yes. And that stretch. But you've got events like the Great Exhibition itself.
就在大理石拱门附近。我想大概在法林顿（Farringdon）一带，你知道的，就在那附近。哦，对的。但法林顿是一个非常非常早的车站，对吧？是的。还有那一段。但你拥有诸如伟大博览会本身的这些活动。
That wouldn't have been possible without the railways. Not just getting all the exhibitions themselves, exhibits themselves down to London, but the paying public as well. And it was a huge success. And if you think about those great, I mean, the Euston Arch is like a triumphal arch. Some people have described it as it.
如果没有铁路，这一切是不可能的。不仅是将所有的展品本身运送到伦敦，还有付费参观的公众也是如此。这是一个巨大的成功。如果你想想那些伟大的建筑——我的意思是，尤斯顿拱门就像是一座凯旋门。有些人曾这样描述过它。
You know, the North is arriving literally in London, you know, with that like the stations kings cross houston and pancras is it it's quite a statement isn't it's quite an architectural but see i think i think the railways um are the i mean you you use the expression the sine qua non i think they are the absolute building block for some of the things we talked about in previous episodes of this podcast so the idea of a national culture we had a whole we did an episode we did episodes about football and cricket you know let's say take football football is a mass spectator sport in which people will follow their team to the cup finals you know and those scenes that you get in sort of early 20th century England of the whole population of Bolton, you know, descending on London or something.
你知道的，北方人字面意义上正在抵达伦敦，你知道的，伴随着国王十字车站、尤斯顿车站和圣潘克拉斯车站这样的存在，这真是一个充满声明意味的存在，不是吗？这是一个相当具有建筑风格的……不过，看，我认为铁路——我的意思是，你用了“必不可少之物”（sine qua non）这个词，我认为它们是我们在这档播客之前各期中讨论过的一些事物的绝对基石。所以关于民族文化的理念——我们做过整整一期节目，我们做过关于足球和板球的节目，你知道的，比如说足球，足球是一项大众观赏性运动，人们会跟随他们的球队去现场观看杯赛决赛，你知道的，你在20世纪初期的英国所看到的那些场景：博尔顿（Bolton）的全体居民，
They are utterly unthinkable without the mass transit possibilities of the railway. And I would argue that what the railway, I mean, the railway is key to me in modern nationalism and the modern national identity in the nation state because it creates a sense of a sort of collective story and a collective culture that would be that and a telegraph and the kind of development of a national mass media
蜂拥来到伦敦之类的。如果没有铁路的大规模运输能力，这些是绝对不可想象的。而且我认为，铁路——我的意思是，铁路对我而言是现代民族主义和现代民族国家中的现代民族身份认同的关键所在，因为它创造了一种集体叙事和集体文化的意识，如果没有这些东西——还有电报以及国家大众媒体的发展，
without those things. And by the way, you wouldn't get the national mass media without the railways because you wouldn't be able to get the newspapers to different parts of the country so quickly. I mean, I think without the railways, you don't get any of that. Also, of course, if you're a private consulting detective in London, you wouldn't be able to get to Dartmoor to solve mysterious crimes involving giant hounds.
顺便说一句，如果没有铁路，你就不会拥有国家大众媒体，因为你无法如此迅速地将报纸送到全国的不同地方。我的意思是，我认为如果没有铁路，这一切都不复存在。当然，如果你是伦敦的一名私人咨询侦探，你也无法前往达特穆尔去侦破涉及巨型猎犬的神秘案件。
I think it's fair to say that about 70% of our podcast episodes depend upon the railways, and the others are all your Greek ones. Oh, another interesting footnote. The national culture point is an interesting one, Dominic. William Henry Smith, key figure, because he spots the opportunity to sell newspapers, periodicals, books. Is he from Northumbria?
我认为可以公平地说，我们大约70%的播客节目都依赖于铁路，而剩下的全都是你们希腊相关的节目。哦，另一个有趣的脚注。关于民族文化的观点很有趣，多米尼克。威廉·亨利·史密斯（William Henry Smith）是个关键人物，因为他发现了销售报纸、期刊和书籍的商机。他是诺森布里亚人吗？
He's not, but he founds W.H. Smith that we wrote. It's now a slightly shabby high street presence. But back in the Victorian age, they'd spotted that it was quite easy to read on trains. And so that national sense of everywhere you go, you see WH Smith, they used to be literally on the platform and then they moved out into the streets around about stations. Obviously the commuter.
他不是，但他创立了我们所熟知的W·H·史密斯书店。如今它在商业街上已经显得有些破旧了。但在维多利亚时代，他们发现人们在火车上阅读相当轻松。因此那种全国性的意识——无论你走到哪里，你都能看到W·H·史密斯书店，它们过去就直接开在月台上，然后才搬到车站周围的街道上。显然还有通勤族。
Yeah, the commuter. The commuter is a railway creation. I mean, people aren't riding their horse into London, you know, to the office. Yeah. Well, it's the invention of suburbia, isn't it, is only possible. The urbanisation itself, you might say,
是的，通勤族。通勤族是铁路的产物。我的意思是，人们可不是骑着马去伦敦上班的，你知道的。嗯，这就是郊区化（suburbia）的发明，没有铁路这是不可能实现的。你可以说，城市化本身
goes hand in hand with the suburbs and you need to be able to travel in. The other great Victorian invention as well, of course, is the seaside holiday you know blackpool scarborough even places like tangmelt and whitley bay in my part of the world you know become easy to get to from the urban centers by train and and the amazing thing is that um although in britain uh mr beachy doctor is it dr beech yes dr beaching kind of cut it all that by the late 19th century the railway reaches almost everywhere in britain i mean you can get almost anywhere you
与郊区的发展是手挽手并肩前行的，而你需要有能力通勤进城。当然，另一个伟大的维多利亚时代的发明是海滨度假，你知道的，布莱克浦（Blackpool）、斯卡伯勒（Scarborough），甚至是我老家的唐茅斯（Tynemouth）和惠特利湾（Whitley Bay）这样的地方，乘火车从城市中心前往都变得轻而易举。而且令人惊奇的是，尽管在英国——比奇博士（Dr Beeching），是比奇博士吗？是的，比奇博士——取消了其中大部分线路，但在19世纪末，铁路几乎延伸到了英国的每一个角落。我的意思是，乘火车你可以到达几乎任何你想去的地方，
want by train completely so that might be a good place i think at which to end this episode because i i dan your intention of doing the whole sweep into the 21st century. He wasn't, he wasn't even going to do the whole, he wasn't going to do the whole period. He was going to do the world. Yeah. Yeah.
完全可以。所以这可能是一个很好的地方，我认为可以以此来结束这一期节目，因为——丹，你想要把整个历史大跨度推进到21世纪的打算……他本没打算这样做，他甚至没打算讲完整个历史时期。他本打算直接讲整个世界。对。对。
So, so we've, so we focused entirely on Britain here, but obviously there is a story going on in the, on the content of Europe, obviously in America with the railroads in India, lots to orient express and all that kind of stuff so there's lots more to talk about would would you be willing to come back in six months or so and
所以，所以我们——我们在这里完全聚焦于英国，但显然欧洲大陆上正在发生着另一个故事，显然美国有铁路，印度也有铁路，还有东方快车以及所有这类事情，所以还有很多可以聊的。你是否愿意在半年左右后再次回归，
we do the railways part two absolutely absolutely and if you could just pay for my research trips on the Orient Express and so on I'll get get back to you. I think the key thing is he needs to wear a different hat. A Homburg or something like that. Well, Dan, I'm assuming that it will still revolve around Newcastle. I don't really see that you need to... Why don't you have a nosebleed
我们来录制铁路第二部分？绝对愿意，绝对愿意。如果你能顺便帮我报销一下东方快车之类的研究旅行费用的话，我会联系你的。我觉得关键点在于他需要戴一顶不同的帽子。一顶罕堡帽（Homburg）或者诸如此类的东西。好吧，丹，我假设这依然会围绕着纽卡斯尔展开。我真的不觉得你需要……
if you start going off to foreign clients? Can I just mention one thing we didn't touch on? Perhaps George Stevenson's greatest legacy do you know what it was, do you know what his culinary gift was to the world? no, oh, is it some sort of
当你开始涉足外国客户时，难道不会流鼻血吗？我能顺便提一件我们没怎么触及的事吗？也许这算得上乔治·斯蒂芬森最伟大的遗产。你知道那是什么吗？你知道他对世界的烹饪贡献是什么吗？不知道。哦，难道是某种
Neil Theiston food stuff, what's it going to be? no, it's even more widespread than that, it's the straight cucumber we have George Stevenson to thank for the straight cucumber, he's a very like a lot of northumbrian men he was a keen allotment gardener and and cucumbers used to grow curly and he had a great rivalry with paxton the gardener at um yeah great exhibition again
诺森布里亚的食物？到底会是什么？不知道。它的普及范围甚至比那还要广，是直黄瓜。我们得感谢乔治·斯蒂芬森发明了直黄瓜。就像许多诺森布里亚男人一样，他是个狂热的 allotment（租地菜园）园丁，而以前黄瓜长出来总是弯曲的。他和帕克斯顿（Paxton）——也就是那位负责……的园丁之间有着激烈的竞争。又是伟大博览会。
yes indeed and basically um stevenson had the lads at his engine engineering workshop in newcastle knock up his cucumber straight now it just looks like a glass condom which you grow your cucumbers in. Before that. But hold on, has that so I'm thinking about modern cucumbers. Are they still doing this? Are they growing them in glass condoms?
确实如此。基本上，嗯，斯蒂芬森让他在纽卡斯尔发动机工程车间的伙计们打造了他的“直黄瓜模具”。现在它看起来就像是一个用来种黄瓜的玻璃安全套。在此之前。等等，这是真的吗？所以我在想现代黄瓜。他们现在还在这么做吗？他们是在玻璃安全套里种黄瓜吗？
I don't know if there's been some sort of genetic change in that after years of growing them in this way they just naturally grow in straight lines there's a cucumbers have a kind of folk memory if it's been bred into them now but certainly we've got george stevenson to thank for the straight cube wow so we can have dan back for the railways and for the history of the cucumbers just salads generally Dan thanks so much my pleasure
我不知道黄瓜是否发生了某种基因变异，在经过多年这样种植之后，它们现在自然就能长成直的了。黄瓜现在也许有一种“民间记忆”，这种特征已经被培育进去了。但可以肯定的是，我们确实要感谢乔治·斯蒂芬森发明了直黄瓜。哇，所以我们可以请丹回来聊聊铁路，顺便聊聊黄瓜的历史，总而言之就是各种沙拉。丹，非常感谢。我的荣幸。
absolute joy as ever and we will we'll welcome you back in six months or so to do Railways Part 2 look forward to that thanks so much excellent
一如既往的绝对快乐。我们会在半年左右后欢迎你回来，录制铁路第二部分。我很期待。非常感谢，太棒了。
thank you very much Dan bye everybody bye bye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢丹。大家再见，再见，谢谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家播客、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。